[Applaudissements]
ouvrez-moi j'ai perdu ma chaussure
merci
de parler à Éric Zemmour à Marion
maréchal ou au Républicain qui dit que
je suis plus radical
vous savez depuis
deux trois ans j'étais présenté dans
tous les dans tous les médias comme le
justement la figure moderne ouverte etc
du rassemblement national et puis depuis
le 5 novembre je suis devenu je suis
devenu un
identitaire plus radical etc moi je suis
rien de tout cela j'ai pas du tout envie
de répondre à mes questions
5 mois seulement après leur élection les
députés se disent déjà au bout du
rouleau nos députés au bord du burnout
ce matin la présidente de l'Assemblée
réunissait les chefs de fil des groupes
parlementaires pour tenter d'améliorer
leurs conditions de travail ce matin
j'entendais beaucoup dans les médias des
sujets sur les députés pas trop fatigué
sans doute sont trop fatigués ils ont
peut-être trop il faut peut-être revoir
le leur façon de travailler etc
quand tu vois les bouchées quand tu vois
les boulangers ça c'est des métiers où
il faut bosser quoi est-ce que nos élus
travaillent plus qu'avant alors si on
compare avec 2017 début du précédent
quinquennat on peut pas vraiment dire
que ça a changé il y a pas plus de
séances de nuit ce sont les statistiques
de l'assemblée il y a 5 ans les députés
ont même passé 43 heures de plus dans
l'hémicycle que cette année en fait ce
qui change tout c'est le contexte
politique la majorité relative ça rend
tout incertain alors dans chaque camp il
faut être attentif au moindre vote et
donc être plus nombreux plus présent
pour faire bloc ce qui a changé en
réalité c'est plutôt les modes d'examen
des textes puisque la majorité relative
impose une mobilisation plus importante
de l'ensemble des forces politiques
traduction avec une majorité absolue il
serait moins claqué
le feu en haut de la tour complètement
vite ce mot
qui a le feu en haut de la tour
qu'est-ce que ça peut être il nous
proposons de manière très simple de
sortir du marché européen de
l'électricité c'est ce qu'a fait
dérouler tout ce que vous voulez il y a
pas de souci mais là je vous pose une
question concrète sur le prix des
transports et comment on règle le
problème là pour la semaine prochaine
pour le mois de janvier on va pas sortir
du marché d'électricité et 6 janvier et
ça va pas faire baisser le prix du métro
ah mais écoutez mais moi j'entends cette
promesse depuis le mois de janvier 70%
des lois qui sont votées ne servent à
rien ne change pas la vie ne sont la
plupart du temps jamais appliqués parce
que les décrets d'application ne sont
jamais mis en place donc il y a une
espèce de folie législative qui fait que
effectivement on est dans un système
absurde en cause des cas d'avance
infernales des horaires de nuit et des
amendements par centaines les députés
sont au bord du burnout titre le JDD
selon Libération même la médecin de
l'Assemblée serait inquiétée pour leur
santé pourquoi est-ce que dans l'Essonne
il y a une école qui est obligée de
fermer il y a une mairie qui a fermé une
parce que le trépad chauffage exactement
donc le sujet c'est la maîtrise de la
courbe des prix de l'énergie et la
solution nous proposons Emmanuel Macron
vous me dites on va pas la faire en
janvier bah Emmanuel Macron la première
janvier 2021 ça n'a pas été fait c'est
peut-être le sujet
je voudrais savoir qu'est-ce que vous
proposez ma réponse
tu en as marre
[Applaudissements]
tu en as marre de cette essence élevée
de tous ces scandales médiatiques qui
commencent à nous prendre la tête à nous
amener dans le négatif si tu veux
changer tout ça je suis mon conseil et
fais comme moi appelle le 36 15 bonheur
un moment donné on se maîtrise à un
moment donné on est la mariée Sandy
un moment donné on a de la prestance et
de l'allure
[Musique]
un geste commercial vous êtes pas
content vous appelez jusqu'à chez pas où
mais mettez ça au tribunal et puis voilà
Monsieur André c'est de ne le prenez pas
comme ça on ne se trouve une solution
avec tout le monde
je comprends bien
mais non ne vous agacez pas André là
c'est la Coupe du Monde c'est la fête on
va essayer de trouver une solution
rappelons que tous vos ballons sont eco
friendly pas du tout par exemple comme
les ballons de la Coupe du Monde au
Qatar voilà je vous dis ça je dis rien
au
Qatar après les équipes ce sont les
supporters qui prennent parti regarder
un homme c'est introduit pour la
première fois sur la pelouse c'était
pendant le match Portugal - Uruguay il
portait un t-shirt en soutien aux femmes
iranienne et un drapeau arc-en-ciel pour
en faveur de l'inclusion nouveau geste
donc contre le bilan humain et
écologique de ce Mondial au Qatar qui
fait en polémique on le surnomme il
Falco le faucon c'est intrépide jeune
homme s'est inventé une profession
envahisseurs de terrain de pourquoi vous
faites ça fait j'ai juste un esprit un
peu barré on vient de recevoir un coup
de téléphone de la FIFA là pour ce qu'on
a montré
si on sort les drapeaux c'est fini il y
a qu'un seul pays dans le monde où les
gens sont civilisés c'est le Japon donc
regarder comment eux ils fêtent la
victoire donc ce qui se passe c'est
qu'il y a le feu rouge donc ils
attendent bien évidemment que le feu
passe au rouge pour aller dans la rue
crier voilà tout le monde est content se
prend dans les bras on est hyper ravis
que le Japon ait gagné contre
l'Allemagne c'était la semaine dernière
et puis d'un coup on va vite s'écarter
parce que le feu va vite passer au vert
il faut bien sûr permettre aux
automobilistes et bien de partir de
passer voilà
c'est ce qui s'appelle la civilisé
à vous j'ai essayé de répondre à vos
questions